what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I have
morning coffee thoughts but my coffee
has not arrived yet so I have no
beverage
um where this if you haven't watched
before this is where I give you guys
life advice or not even life advice just
like morning thoughts that I have
about society and life um but before I
start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification Bell
that we are going to be notified of my
daily videos I may be checking my phone
during this to see what my coffee's
gonna get here
let's see
it said it could be in the next five to
15 minutes so I guess we'll see if I get
it
um okay so today I'm going to talk about
how your biggest haters can become your
biggest fans
and it's interesting because I've been
on both sides of this
um
I've disliked certain content creators
when I first saw their content
and I became their biggest fans later
because you know you would see a 30
second clip or 60 second clip or you
just wouldn't really understand the
general point that they're making like
for example when I first got in
interested in red pill content
I think one of the biggest things that I
fought back on was cheating I did not
like cheating because I didn't grow up
in an area that cheating was common
um my parents never had any issues with
that I know y'all guys will put cap in
the comments but I'm telling you
um my parents are very loyal people so
they've never really had any issues with
that and I just didn't grow up in a
place that that was socially acceptable
and to me like that was like one of the
worst things you could do to someone is
cheat okay so there were certain content
creators that I would see their content
they would talk about cheating
um one I can think of off the top of my
head is Andrew Tate I really
wasn't the biggest fan when I saw this
stuff on cheating I was like I don't
like that I think that's bad
however fast forward a year later I
understand what they were saying
and maybe I was triggered when I first
saw it but
what they were saying was
the men that you want are rare and if
you go after those men they will likely
cheat on you does it mean they will it
doesn't mean they all do there's loyal
men that don't but just know
if you go after those guys they might
cheat and what will you do if they what
will you do if they do
and I think that honestly is a fair
point it's a fair point and sometimes I
may not have liked the way they said it
I may not have liked
how they came across and maybe I got
triggered along the way but
it was a fair point and I've noticed
this that some of the people that
I really pushed back against in the
beginning I actually ended up being
their biggest fans
and that's why now when I'm in the
position I'm at I really don't take [ __ ]
talking personal
um a lot of times in the manosphere not
even the manosphere just like in general
I've noticed this more with guys than
women
um and I think it's because as women
like we're just kind of used to our
friends [ __ ] talking us
um so we don't really take it as
personally like we don't we won't never
talk to you again if you said something
mean or said you know it's just like
kind of part of being a woman and maybe
that's an uncomfortable truth
but
you know I think at times men and women
have both gotten angry or upset and said
things they don't mean and I've noticed
the people that have gotten the most
upset with me in the beginning and long
term
they kind of it's it's interesting
because they end up being the biggest
fans
and that's like what's interesting and I
noticed on the other end of it when I
was a washer instead of the Entertainer
I had a similar
you know pushback like where I would
first see this stuff and it was just all
really new to me and I didn't understand
what they were saying I didn't
understand the broader point they were
making so when Kevin Samuel said high
value man men can cheat I was like
what this guy is this this guy is that
like I you know I was like why would
anyone think that
until you know you really lay out the
numbers and you really think about it
and then you know I went from oh my God
to I don't feel bad that you get cheated
on
if you're an NBA player or if you date
an NBA player I don't
and
maybe in the beginning you might have a
visceral reaction but my whole point the
point isn't even like the red pill
Journey the point is that
sometimes
the people that hate you actually love
you and people think I'm crazy when I
say this when I say this I have someone
that works for me and I always I always
tell them I'm like because he'll hear
um he did recruiting for me and he sort
of like helps out with it from time to
time and he'll hear the back end like
the girl's talking [ __ ] about me and
like so I'll kind of sometimes hear the
things that the women say about me after
they leave the show which will be
interesting because they'll be perfectly
Pleasant on the show
and then they leave and they're like now
they're talking [ __ ] and now I'm the bad
but but
so my point is this my point is this
what I've noticed is the girls that
leave and talk [ __ ]
I would always tell him that they're
obsessed with me and they actually love
me and I'm like they might say they hate
me but they love me ask me how I know
because if they hate you enough to talk
about you that means you have their
attention and attention is currency and
this this is kind of a theory so don't
don't quote me on this and say this is
like gospel but if you have their
attention and they hate you it's kind of
Closer to Love Like if I really don't
like someone I'm just indifferent and I
never put their name in my mouth again
I'm like I'm not dealing with them ever
again but
if you hate me enough like there's a
girl in London that was always on our
story she always sub tweeting me always
all of this she goes around talking to
all these people about how awful I am
blah blah blah has this whole she like
started this hate Community against me
and I'm like okay and I I bet you that
girl wants to come back on the show she
ain't never coming back
but it's just funny because I bet you if
she came back on I don't know what the
psychology is I bet you some of the
girls that come on they have a bad
experience they come back on
they end up loving me then they're my
biggest fans and I don't know maybe it's
the highs and the lows that never know
what you're gonna get I don't know what
it is but I've just noticed that some
people that I look back and watch my old
videos of me reacting to and I was like
oh I don't like them I'm like oh my God
I'm the biggest fan now and I've noticed
that it's the same thing with me girls
that like hate me at first
they'll come back and they're like yeah
I'm the biggest fan I under I understood
what you were saying and sometimes
people might have a visceral reaction to
what you're saying but just know that
when the truth is on your side it
doesn't matter like you can't outrun
truth
um
and if the truth is on your side
people come around eventually and I've
had people I've had people stop being my
friend over things
they have stopped being my friend and
they came back around and said you know
what you were right
you were right I just didn't like
hearing it
and
yeah and that's that's my theory that
the people that hate you secretly love
you and they might not even know that
they love you they might not even know
they might not even know but
they they secretly love you
um but that's why I'm
um I saw an old interview with Andrew
Tate and it was on John Anthony
Lifestyles Channel
um it was a very very old video
um and it was him being interviewed
about people that have like talked [ __ ]
about him and I thought his attitude was
the attitude that I strived to have it's
hard it is hard because you hear the
things that people say sometimes and
you're like what did it like you have
this emotional reaction but he
he his reaction was like you know what
I have nothing against them I think they
seem like nice guys
um
objectively like he did say like
objectively I don't think their
girlfriends are attractive just
objectively but they're nice guys
because they're talking about like the
valid validity of dating coaches and
blah like I don't know but the what
stood out to me wasn't
who's valid in the dating coach
Community whatever it was Andrew Tate's
reaction to people that talk [ __ ] about
him and that's something my dad has
again as a woman not as a woman as a
person
it is hard but the less personal you can
take people talking [ __ ] because this is
another phenomenon I've noticed and I
noticed it in volleyball
when there would be a girl in the
beginning of the Season people hated and
they would talk so much [ __ ] about her
they hated her and by the end of the
season they were like throwing her a
birthday party and I was like how does
she go from like the least liked girl on
the team to the most liked and that's
what I realized I'm like it is the same
thing
hate and love are the same being
indifference that is hate because I I've
noticed it with men and women too like
the ex that they hate that they hate
that's who they loved that's like and so
in that interview
Andrew Taylor was like yeah they seem
like nice guys and that I think is the
best approach with people that don't
like you is
it's kind of like you just say oh yeah
they seem like nice people you know I
mean I heard they said some stuff but
whatever because at the end of the day
it doesn't really matter what people say
people can talk and talk and talk but
it's like their actions and how they
treat you that matters and people get
mad and sometimes they'll say things to
a friend who spills the beans or
sometimes you know they they're
emotional in the moment and even me like
there have been times where someone
pissed me off and I said things that I
regret or I said things that I didn't
really mean and if they took that
personally they might think that I
actually hated them but no I was just
mad in the moment
oh my coffee's here hold on guys let me
you can come with me to get my coffee
ah
hello thank you
foreign
I think sometimes people think that this
my um Studio looks like an only fan
Studio when they look in because
um
I have all these cameras set up in my
living room for the show yeah and it
kind of looks like only fans but
my point is this like
I
I don't think [ __ ] talking matters
um
that much as much as I used to like I
used to take it more personally but my
dad kind of taught me this too because
he would always say
I would say Dad this person said this
this oh no sleep
like my Dad sorry now can I'm here
I would be like Dad this person said
this this and this about me and my dad
would be like who cares
who cares like
um so so what so what and and and and
I'd be like but Dad but Dad
that's so meaner but like should I never
talk to them again he's like okay deal
with them less who cares and it's a
really again this isn't an easy mindset
to have I see men that I consider great
men that I consider like
top tier like
oh my gosh like men I look up to and
they're still like worrying about what
other people say and my point is you're
never really gonna know what people say
behind your back so why worry about it
what matters is how they treat you
and their actions
um because people can say they hate you
but they secretly love you I hope I'm
making sense I don't even know if this
is like
making sense but this is this is my
point
hate is closer to love okay
the people that say they hate you they
secretly love you but they don't even
know it
um
people say things in the moment that
they don't mean so don't take people
talking [ __ ] too personal
um
you're never really gonna know what they
say
and
oh God that's a bad coffee I don't like
that it needs more sugar
um
yeah I think that's my main points but
anyways let me know what you guys think
I hope this is coherent enough to make
sense
um subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell and I'll talk to you
next time